wilson takes the bump for the pirates
13 appearances between atlanta and the
bucks a two and six record a 460 era
nice little run here
55 games
with
washington
this one headed up the middle
and
newman and moran combined to rob escobar
kevin newman wow now that was pretty
impressive right there i guess we'll
have to see if uh colin moran was able
to stay on
first base but newman how quickly he
went to his left and how quickly he got
rid of that throw and then they got him
turns on that one
and where's the baseball for colin moran
the call is safe
josh bell playing hard he dove into
first the other night on a double play
dove into first here
he is playing hard he is hustling
and he is hitting the ball right on the
nose
and now bouncer back to him
and this time it goes instead of what
should have been a 3-1 put out to end
the top of the first it's a 1-3 put out
and the pirates come to bat patrick
corbin nine career starts against the
pirates
three and two with a 3-1-9 era lefty
patrick corbin has had
difficulty keeping the ball in the
ballpark that is something we will watch
and there's a hard hit ball wasting no
time
into center for key brian
[Applause]
hayes as the runners break in the ground
ball that will keep the pirates out of a
double play
fire
this one from high home looks like an
out to me
they will get a base hit and a walk and
each team strands a couple in the first
luis garcia intentionally walked last
night only time in the series she's been
aboard 0 for seven against the bucks
center cut fastball this one heading for
the gap see
you later number five for luis nice
catch buddy but the nats still lead one
nothing wilmer defoe will lead it off
for the pirates
sit up
center field thomas not going to get
there he's gotten to a lot
most everything in this series but not
that little soft serve single to center
for depot
fights this one off and drops this one
into center field and defo
will hold up as thomas got to it quickly
it's first and second nobody out
all right here comes the runner defoe
will score
that's a great great call with two
strikes bryce wilson ties it
yep that's a great call and a great read
by defoe i mean i assume it's a it could
have been just the safety squeeze where
defoe was breaking on you know any bunt
that got away from that home plate dirt
circle obviously he wasn't breaking when
the ball was bunted right at home plate
but he saw this ball get
hit bunted pretty firmly and corbin opts
to take the out at first
bunnett his last time around
oh that's rope toward left center field
there's his first hit off corbin
stays in play
and he's headed to third
and that's a trip trip triple for kevin
newman
gotta love the triple kevin newman gets
a center cut fastball turns on and we've
seen him hit for more power hitting more
gap shots in the last month or two
the left fielder harnett is just now
moving to straightaway left here's the
pitch and it's swinging a fly ball out
to center but right at thomas
he's sizing it up he'll make the catch
got a decent arm newman runs well he's
off third and he's in there easily
sacrifice fly for reynolds
and the pirates take a 2-1 lead alex
sevilla to moran with a grounder first
time first base two two two outs
and avila gets a pitch up tries to park
one to right
c
u
later top row of the bleachers
his first of the year
and the 105th of his big league career
that's on top with the long ball the
long ball actually tying it with the
long ball
and then this ball gashed out to right
center by adrian sanchez
that's playing pepper with right and
right center here at pnc loud noises
everywhere and that gets corbin into the
box in the fourth
inning
corbin the other way base set sanchez
around third he will hold because alford
against the pitcher was playing super
shallow we'll see if thomas can give the
nationals a run scoring hit to put him
in front
that was center cut hits it well right
field
c
u later
three run shot two out lightning indeed
and then that's five two
now the pitch hayes takes fastball is in
there strike three called
patrick corbin
has his second strikeout at two quick
outs here on the bottom of the fifth
penny and it will be adrian sanchez to
lead off
there's the breaking ball ripped to left
adrian sanchez is two for three
we've seen the defense the range
strong arm sharply hit
and look at
default
drops the ball they still have the man
caught between second and third tagged
by oviedo nobody at first they would
have had a triple play
juan soto two walks are on to fly ball
to left
waits for a breaking ball hits it to
right center lots of carry off the glove
of gammel then it bounces past reynolds
and juan soto's digging for three
digging hard
three bagger one soto his second triple
of the year eighth of his career oh and
one to yadiel who's driven in 26 on the
air
and he'll drive one out to center to
make it 27th
soto win
that's adding on nicely at six to two
daniel hernandez went one for 11 until
his lasted bat now he has two hits in a
row
and a swing and a miss wow
that's a corbin i know he's at a hundred
plus might that buy him another inning
i'm with you he's on cruise control
right now here's mason thompson for the
nat's
21st game of the year first appearance
of this series
perfect
hayes couldn't pull the trigger outer
half one out 97 paint he tripled and
scored in the third inning his third
triple of the season
and he has a ground single to right
putting to a board
[Music]
finnegan slowed down his bat
yadiel has it the bucks loser runner at
third finnegan gets reynolds and we can
all take an exhale into the night wilmer
defoe has not faced kyle before as it
does for the nats one strike to go to
get back home
busted bat escobar
nats win it
in three hours and six minutes patrick
corbin sets the tone for the staff gets
his eighth win cal finnegan gets his
ninth save thomas hits a three-run homer
avila goes deep garcia goes deep it's
enough to make you want to hug all your
teammates
you